How Much are Olympic Gold medals Worth?
As far as the value of the raw materials in
them, this varies from Olympiad to Olympiad.
For the recent 2012 Olympics in London, the
medals were the largest of any in Summer Olympic
history up to that point, weighing in at 400g
for the gold medal. Of this 400g, 394g was
sterling silver (364.45g silver / 29.55g copper)
with 6g of 24 karat gold plating. At the price
of gold and silver when these medals were
won by various Olympians, this means a gold
medal in the London Olympics was worth about
$624, with $304 of the value coming from the
gold plating and about $320 coming from the
sterling silver. Since then, the price of
gold has dropped about 18% and the price of
silver has dropped about 39%.
For the current 2016 Rio Olympics, the gold
medals are one-upping the London Games, weighing
in at a a half a kilogram, with about 462g
of it silver, 6g gold, and the rest copper.
So by current gold and silver prices as of
July 13, 2016, these medals are worth about
$561 total, with approximately $301 of the
value from silver and $260 from gold. So,
despite being 1/5 more massive than the London
Games Olympics medals, and having the same
amount of gold and much more silver, due to
the significant drop in gold and silver prices
since 2012, the Rio gold medals are worth
less at their awarding than the London Games
medals were worth when they were awarded.
Of course, athletes can often get much more
than this selling the medals on the open market,
particularly for momentous medals, like the
“Miracle on Ice” 1980 men’s U.S. hockey
team gold medal. Mark Wells, a member of that
team, auctioned his medal off in 2012 and
received $310,700 for it, which he needed
to help pay for medical treatment.
Most auctioned medals don’t go for nearly
this much, though. For instance, Anthony Ervin’s
50 meter freestyle gold medal won in 2000,
even with all proceeds going to the victims
of the Indian Ocean tsunami, only sold for
$17,100. John Konrads’ 1500 meter freestyle
gold medal won in 1960 only sold for $11,250
in 2011. This is a great return in terms of
what the raw value of the materials are worth,
but certainly nowhere close to Mark Wells’
medal.
Gold medals in the Olympics weren’t always
made mostly of silver. Before the 1912 Olympics,
they were made of solid gold. However, they
tended to be much smaller than modern medals.
For instance, the 1900 Paris gold medals were
only 3.2 mm thick, with a 59 mm diameter,
weighing just 53g. For perspective, the London
2012 medals were 7 mm thick, with a diameter
of 85 mm and, as mentioned, weighed 400g.
The 1900 Paris gold medals at today’s value
of gold are worth about $2300. For the 1912
games in Stockholm, the last year the gold
medals were made of solid gold, the value
of the gold medals at current prices of gold
would be around $870.
If the current 2016 Olympic gold medals were
made out of solid gold, they’d be worth
about $21,625 each. This may seem feasible,
considering how much money the Olympics brings
in, until you consider just how many medals
are awarded during each summer Olympics. For
instance, in these 2016 Olympics, about 2,488
medals have been produced, including 812 gold
medals. At $21,625 each, that would be just
shy of $18 million dollars for the gold medal
materials alone.
As it is, with the current gold medals having
about $561 worth of materials, then $305 for
the silver medals, and about $5 for the bronze
(which are mostly made of copper, with a very
small amount of zinc and tin), about $708,000
is still being spent on the raw materials
alone for these medals, not to mention the
cost of having them minted.